what can the police legally do and say
during an interrogation well they can't
physically harm you but police can lie
they can pretend they have evidence
against you when they don't or act like
they're trying to help you when they're
really trying to get you to confess the
only limits are that they can't threaten
you make promises or lie about the
punishment for a crime when it comes to
kids or people with low IQs who are more
vulnerable to coercion there aren't many
more rules only a few states require a
parent be present for an interrogation
most say a parent or guardian should be
notified
but 17 states don't have any laws
requiring an adult to be present the law
does require a confession be obtained
voluntarily but in the end what that
means is usually left up to a judge or
jury to decide